in this video i want to talk to you
about how to eliminate problems in your
life without taking any action and as
crazy as that may sound i think that
what i will share with you may sound
even crazier if you don't know who i am
my name is alex mosey on acquisition.com
it's portfolio of companies those over
100 million dollars a year and i have
nothing to sell you and this lovely uh
dolphin background painting is because
my wife i've been traveling a lot and
we're in random airbnbs so that being
said let's rock and roll so yesterday i
was having a conversation with an old
friend of mine and we have different
beliefs around the topic of problems
especially when it comes to the human
condition and i went on somewhat of a
rant about this topic and i figured i
would encapsulate it here for you guys
and so the problem that this individual
was talking about was a lot of stuff
that has to do with you know mental
illness and mental health and i think
that this is a an interesting topic
because
the entire like industry didn't even
exist until a few hundred years ago and
humans have existed for a long period of
time one of the more interesting things
about the mental illness category is the
importance of labeling and if you
followed me for any period of time
you'll know that labeling to me is one
of the strongest powers that exists in
the mind and i'll give you a reason why
our minds are meaning making machines
and so what that means is we
determine what is meaningful and what is
not and then we ascribe labels to them
in terms of positive and negative
because that is how we survive now that
being said our brains are meant to keep
us alive not meant to help us thrive
right to use a rhyming word for you now
that being said with this whole concept
around labeling it's something that i'm
probably most passionate about like the
concept of labeling as a whole it's
unbelievably powerful when it comes to
persuading people to do things
unbelievably powerful when it comes to
changing people's world views and their
perspectives on life and i will share a
few of those examples with you so i'll
give you a quick persuasion example for
how powerful this is if i wanted to
persuade someone to do something then
what i would do is i would create a
positive label that i would associate
them with so i would say you are
probably a loving and caring man for you
know you want to provide support for
your family is that true they're like
yes and i'm like yeah you definitely
seem like one of those types of people
and since you are one of those types of
people i think that you should invest in
this program that we have because that
would be an alignment with this ideal
that we just labeled the person with and
so what happens is it creates cognitive
dissonance because for the person in
order for them to stay in accordance
with the label that they would like to
have they then feel obligated to then
act in accordance with that label that
we just prescribed now that's a very
simplistic example you can weave that
into narratives and sales scripts so
that people become psychologically
labeled and then want to act in
accordance with that label because they
see it as positive right the thing is is
that it can also work in reverse in
terms of how you can harm someone and
the reason that this is so viscerally
upsetting to me is that i have had
members of my family extended and what
not who have i would say debilitated
themselves in large part because of what
they believe to be mental illness and i
disagree now many people will get
triggered at this and so i will say my
big disclaimer which is this is not
financial advice this is not grammatical
advice this is not spiritual advice this
is not even advice this is a guy making
a youtube video about stuff that pisses
me off and hopefully some of the things
that serve me well now let's talk about
the labels that are negative one of the
things one of the most pernicious acts
that exists negative bad stuff is when
we take the human experience that has
ups and downs that has extremes that
exist on continuums and we label one
side of the continuum as bad and the
other side of the continuum is good for
example happy
sad
energized or weak tired right we have
equal opposites
you know relaxed stressed right there's
lots of examples of these the reason
that this is so dangerous when we give a
positive or negative label is that
people think that they have a problem
when they are not feeling happy or
energized or
relaxed or clear-minded versus foggy you
know what i mean whatever and the thing
is is in order for there to be light
there must be darkness think about that
for a second
in order for there to be good there must
also be bad
one if you want to admit the existence
of one there must also be the existence
of the other
right awesome now the problem this is
why we have to be careful with labels
that most people suffer from is that
they label normal variations in the
human condition with negative
experiences and so they see themselves
as tired and say this is bad whereas
it's really just part of the human
condition they see themselves as sad
rather than happy and see that as bad
and so what happens is you start to
upgrade a finite emotional condition
into a long-standing emotional
disturbance because
you think it's a problem and the thing
is it's very easy to sell people on why
these things are our problems big pharma
is is the king of this are you feeling
tired
stressed you know are you hungry are you
horny well you are suffering from being
a human being it's being human and so i
think a lot of this and the reason that
it wraps into the original part of the
prompt of this video is that if we want
to be enduring entrepreneurs we want to
be people who have resilience we want
people who have mental fortitude we must
be careful about the things that we
label and there's also the good bad
label which is the simplest label that a
lot of people ascribe to conditions that
are that are
ephemeral right there they're brief
right and then they change but there's
also
the shoulds have
must
need to etc that we say in our lives
that we have to do these things we must
do these things and if we do not or else
we put out a threat towards the universe
if i don't get my coffee i must get my
coffee i need to have coffee before i
start my day what happens is that we
create these implied threats to
ourselves and the universe if we don't
then what right and so i see this and
this is probably the number one thing
that people when i'm having
conversations with them it's teaching
yourself to listen for these language
patterns because they are indications of
in my opinion broken thought patterns
people ascribe positive and negatives
to things without understanding what the
deep ramifications of those things are
and so if you are unhappy awesome you're
human this is the human existence if you
are tired awesome it will create more
contrast for when you are awake if you
are stressed
amazing it will give you contrast for
when you are relaxed if we constantly
want to eliminate one side of the
continuum what often happens is that we
get neither side and we become numb to
the continuum as a whole and so we end
up missing out on some of the human
experience and that's okay if that's
what you want to do but the reason i'm
making this video is that a lot of
people think they have problems that are
not actually problems at all they're
just part of being human and i think the
biggest problem that most people have is
that they define being human as the
problem which inherently is why they
suffer so much and i'll say something
else that was pissing this person off
yesterday that i will i will reinforce
with you which is
suffering is optional and an easy uh
story to to to reinforce this point or
extreme example of this is you if you've
read uh victor frankl's uh man's search
for meaning and it's a very visceral
description if you haven't read it of uh
of auschwitz in the prison camps uh
during world war ii he basically posits
in the book and this is a one-line
summary that's doing a massive disjust
uh injustice to the book that between
circumstance and response is choice and
that is the power that all of us have
even when he was stripped of everything
that he possibly could have he still had
choice and so in that gap is where i
believe we find the human experience we
find how we define how we choose to live
it drives me up a wall because i feel
like a lot of people suffer because they
feel like the way that they're living is
somehow wrong or bad or non-optimal or
they need to take a pill or an injection
to solve being human and i think if we
can simply change our expectations about
what being human really means and i say
this passionately because i very much
suffered from this for a very long
period of time i was obsessed with being
happy and in being obsessed with being
happy anytime i was not happy i saw it
as bad rather than a part of being human
and i drove myself nuts i think i made
myself more unhappy now i say this now
not as though the being more unhappy is
bad or good but i think that most people
want to
decrease their emotional disturbances
that they experience right and so i
think a key to not suffering is a
understanding that the human experience
has
peaks and troughs and it is normal and
it is okay and as a side note one of the
strongest mental health things that i
did for myself and i'll share with you
things that worked for me is that i
created a mental refrain it's just a
simple thing that i can say to myself in
my mind over and over and over again is
that when i'm experiencing a negative
quotes here negative part of the human
experience i'll say and that's okay
that's all be like i'm really annoyed
right now i'll be like and that's okay
rather than casting judgment on the
emotion because a lot of times you don't
have control over your emotions but you
do have control over the judgment with
which you apply to the emotion that you
experience and the response that you
have as a result and so i think this is
where
power is formed as humans
is that some people
two people are exposed to the same
stimulus right same circumstances and
one person perseveres and the other
person does not and a lot of it is
because of the choices that we make
between circumstance and response and
that's kind of back to victor frankl's
thing i'll wrap off this this this final
little thing here this rant um with a
quote from i think it was i think it's
socrates he said wisdom begins with a
definition of terms and so
most arguments or disagreements can be
resolved if both people come to an
agreement on terms and it's because we
say things like happy we say things like
healthy we say things like wealthy we
say things like success right and we
haven't defined the terms yet and then
two people will have different
definitions of what those terms mean or
more likely non-existent definitions
because they've never even thought about
it right some amorphous word that they
throw out bucket some general ideas and
disagree but they have very different
definitions of those things and the way
that you define the outcomes that you
want to experience will help you achieve
them if that is what you so desire and i
think that there's a tremendous amount
of wisdom in that concept because you
know in socrates is quote because like
for example when we sold our three of
the companies that we sold last year
right gym launch prestige labs and allen
we sold those to different buyers and
what was interesting to me was when i
read through the contracts the first
half of like 50 plus page contracts were
just defining the terms
and i thought that was just so
interesting that in order to come to an
agreement we must first agree on terms
right what is the scope or territory of
a non-compete and then there would be a
paragraph and then that word non-compete
would be put somewhere else and the
actual agreements themselves oftentimes
are very simplistic it's like party a as
defined by you know appendix one agrees
to sell right cell being defined in you
know in appendix two to party b right as
defined by
said assets set assets to find it you
know i mean and so what happens is when
you become clear about the words you say
you can communicate and think more
clearly and a lot of times i think that
this resolves a lot of the emotional
disturbances that we experience as
humans because we realize that they were
never problems to begin with only that
we define them that way and therein lie
the problem of how we experience them
and so this is something i'm very very
passionate about hopefully the topic was
not as amorphous as hopefully it sounded
to you but people suffer because they
choose to define their experience as
suffering and i think that many of us
can
experience fewer emotional disturbances
or not upgrade them to long-standing
emotional disturbances by simply saying
a i'm experiencing this emotion which
will pass
comma and it's okay and b subset this is
part of being human and then what
happens is we can start redefining what
the human experience should be and if we
say for example
that
experiencing the full spectrum of the
human experience is a life well lived
and we desire to have a life well lived
then we are doing a good thing when we
suffer when we are sad when we are
stressed because we are living
our life to both extremes
at different times in different seasons
to the fullest degree so that we can
look back on our lives and say i was a
human being i lived this life and
anyways these are things that keep me up
when i think about what it means to be
human
and i think buddha had a really
interesting concept around this which is
you know he talks about the middle path
um in life which is by the way a lot of
people don't know this but you know
buddha was a prince beforehand so he had
all the riches he had all the comforts
right and then he went to extreme
poverty on the other side of the
spectrum and he was like the middle path
right so it's understanding both sides
of the human experience and not saying
either one is good or bad but they just
are
and then i think when we do that we we
remove the judgment of self which is
where a lot of the suffering occurs
rather than simply being present for the
experience and enjoying it for what it
is which is just being human and we
don't fall prey to the narrative of the
big pharmas that say that being human is
wrong being human is bad experiencing
emotions is not normal it's the most
normal thing it's the most normal thing
for people to be unhappy sometimes it's
the most normal thing for people to be
tired sometimes it's normal to be hungry
it's normal to be horny it is part of
being human and we create so much
suffering for ourselves
by saying that there is a problem with
simply existing during a period of time
on a continuum and then that problem
that we label then becomes long-standing
rather than something that passes with
time so lots of love everyone
mozy nation appreciate you if you're new
to the channel welcome lots of love
either way i have nothing to sell you
keep being awesome i'll catch you next
vid bye